in 2019 you'd probably have to stumble
across a group of scientists to hear
people casually talking about antibodies
now discussions of antibodies and immune
response are dinner table conversation
you might have seen these little
y-shaped representations of antibodies
and news articles
but what do they really look like and
how do they help us fight off infection
in this lesson i'll touch on the
importance of antibodies examine their
structure in detail and visualize how
they interact with and neutralize a
viral protein
let's get started antibodies are
proteins produced by b cells that are
part of our immune systems antibodies
bind to antigens which is something the
body recognizes as foreign like a
bacteria virus or allergen
the threat doesn't even need to come
from outside on a small scale antibodies
can bind to a tumor cell and facilitate
its destruction and this is the basis
for some cancer treatments these
y-shaped molecules bind antigens at the
tips of two identical arms
the rest of the antibody is made up of
constant domains
the repeated patterns of protein
structure in the constant domains are
conserved that is they're the same
in antibodies of the same class and
there are five of these antibody classes
or isotypes you might be wondering how
the body can recognize a foreign
substance that it's never encountered
before
well the amino acid sequence where the
antibody binds the antigen at the tips
here is variable
while the b cell is developing the genes
that code for the antigen binding region
which i've colored slightly lighter here
are shuffled up like a deck of cards
this produces many different amino acid
sequences in this region here called the
variable domain
each b cell therefore produces a unique
antibody
but all antibodies produced by that
specific b cell are the same
the first antibodies the b cell produces
are attached to the cell's surface
and if that b cell happens to bind an
antigen
it can be stimulated to produce more
antibodies some of which can float
freely in our bloodstream and lymphatic
systems with that in mind let's take a
deep dive into antibody structure
this is an immunoglobulin g or igg
antibody that we're looking at here
igg is the main antibody in the blood
and the only one that can cross the
placenta
transferring immunity from a mother to a
fetus the antibody is made up of four
different protein chains
two identical light chains which are
shown here in magenta
the two larger chains shown in blue
contain more amino acid residues and are
therefore heavier than the light chains
these heavy chains meet up to form a
region called fc
within the fc there are two identical
carbohydrate chains
bound to the protein through a covalent
bond with the side chain of an
asparagine amino acid residue
in addition to stabilizing the
immunoglobulin structure these
carbohydrates may play a role in
antibody secretion and antigen
elimination focusing on the antigen
binding region for a moment
let's recolor the antibody to show the
domain that binds the antigen in a
softer color scheme
but still show the coloring of the heavy
and light chains
notice both the heavy and light chains
contribute to the variable domain that
binds the antigen now there's a
repeating structural motif throughout
the entire protein
this is the immunoglobulin fold
i'll apply a new color scheme to
highlight each of the 12 immunoglobulin
folds in this structure
let's focus in on a single motif to
examine the fold in detail
the beta sheets twist and tangle which
makes it challenging to really
understand the fold when it's a solid
color i'll apply a rainbow color scheme
and let's reorient this structure so we
can follow the motif from the n-terminus
to the c-terminus
conveniently with the cartoon
representation we just need to follow
the arrows the immunoglobulin fold is
made up of about 110 amino acid residues
that form two tightly packed
anti-parallel beta sheets
starting with the blue n-terminal beta
strand a
we can follow the secondary structure
through a short helical segment into
strand b
shown in cyan a light blue
now we twist around into strand c
which connects to the short strand d
through a flexible loop
twisting back around strand e connects
to strand f through a short 310 helix
we find the seventh strand strand g at
the c terminus
finally there's a disulfide bond
covalently linking two cysteine residues
in the b and f beta strands
this is the form of the immunoglobulin
fold in every one of the constant
domains
the immunoglobulin fold is slightly
different in the variable domains let's
check out one of those
applying the rainbow color scheme once
again
and focusing on the n-terminal beta
strand
here's strand a
a flexible loop connects this to strand
b and again we'll need to rotate our
structure to see the connection to
strand c
shown in blue green
now there's quite a difference
this strand connects to two additional
strands which are named by convention c
prime and c double prime
these continue into strands d and e
which link around to strands f and g
shown in orange and red at the
c-terminal end
there are nine strands in the variable
domain immunoglobulin fold compared to
seven in the constant domains
and here's the disulfide bond linking
the b and f strands
antibody structure is cool and all but
seeing an antibody interact with an
antigen is really interesting
so let's take a peek at the antibody
antigen interaction that's made the
immune system a topic of casual
conversation
and explore a human antibody that binds
to the sars covi2 coronavirus spike
protein
the spike protein is located on the
surface of the sars cov2 virus
it binds to the ace2 receptor on human
cells to cause infection
i've got a video on this interaction if
you want to check it out but this video
is focused on antibodies
here we're looking at a side view of the
spike protein
and let's switch from surface
representation to cartoon to view
specific interactions more easily
here's the spike protein with an
antibody
but this isn't the real structure
i've overlapped the whole antibody that
we were looking at before with the
antibody that binds to spike to help you
orient yourself to this structure
you see when studying proteins
structural biologists rarely look at the
entire antibody because it's difficult
to get a good resolution structure and
see everything clearly
instead many antibodies are cleaved in
specific locations
using protease enzymes
and the structure is solved with an
antibody fragment
a specific protease named propane will
cleave the antibody right about here
lopping off the two antigen binding
fragments called fabs for short
the fab consists of the variable domains
from both the heavy and light chain plus
a constant domain from each
all conveniently held together by the
disulfide bonds that make up the
immunoglobulin fold
after the protein is cleaved the fc
domain can be separated from the fab
domains and the fabs alone are used in
the binding experiment oh and by the way
fc stands for crystallizable fragment
when researchers had just started to
study the cleavage of antibodies with
proteases they found out that this
fragment was easy to crystallize
returning to the structure at hand
let's switch over to the actual antibody
fab that's bound to spike
in this structure there are actually
three fabs bound in three different
regions of the spike protein
this particular antibody binds spike in
an inactive conformation
preventing it from changing to the shape
it needs to adopt to infect cells
but let's just focus on one fab to
explore the molecular interactions that
allow this antibody to neutralize spike
and let's recolor spike white so the red
oxygen atoms will be easy to see
zooming in on the antibody spike
interface will show the amino acids that
can interact as sticks
some of the interactions stabilizing the
structure are hydrogen bonds like this
short strong one that forms between the
o h group on tyrosine and the negatively
charged aspartate side chain
remember in these structures the
hydrogen atoms aren't usually shown
another side chain side chain
interaction that promotes antibody
binding
is this hydrogen bond
between this negatively charged
glutamate and the hydrogen of the serine
hydroxyl group
side chain backbone interactions also
promote binding
like the interaction of this positively
charged lysine with this carbonyl group
on the protein main chain
though weaker van der waals interactions
are also important in binding
and we see a network of these dispersion
forces driving the interaction of this
phenylalanine on spike with tyrosine
residues on both the heavy and light
chains of the antibody here's another
one
this time between a phenylalanine from
the heavy chain and a tryptophan on
spike
and another
this time between a tryptophan and a
valine
antibody antigen binding kicks off the
immune response that allows the body to
fight infection
part of this is the formation of more b
cells that produce the antibody
as the b cells divide some fine tuning
occurs
in a process called somatic
hypermutation
the antigen binding region undergoes
additional mutations which change some
of the amino acids
particularly in loop regions called cdrs
some of these mutated antibodies won't
bind at all
but some will bind better and the b
cells that produce these superior
antibodies will become long-lived memory
b cells that can quickly respond to
similar antigens in the future
scientists can also facilitate the
process of superior antibody production
understanding molecular interactions can
help us engineer antibodies that can
serve as antivirals antibiotics and even
cancer treatments